thanks for joining me today
jupiter notebooks have pretty much
become the standard for data science and
data analytics teams
yeah however there is still a number of
pain points when it comes to working
with them and today i will explain how
we tackle these problems in datelore
which is the data science notebook
platform we built at jetbrains
it is available in cloud and enterprise
uh setups but first let me quickly
introduce myself uh thanks for the
organizers who already did but yeah i
just wanted to add that i do product
marketing for uh data lore and i
graduated as a data scientist and
generally like i'm passionate about
marketing and tech and for the last five
years i've been a heavy user of jupiter
notebooks
and jupiter has a really great community
and is probably one of the most
successful open source projects ever
and
many tools are in fact built using
jupiter technology and data lore is not
an exception here
however classic jupiter or jupiter
notebooks as well as many solutions
built upon it aren't free from the
inherent problems and first let's talk
about setting up environments when you
start working on a computational
notebook you normally begin by setting
up your work environments and installing
all the packages you might need
and there are
two very different ways how you can do
so in a traditional notebook
on the one hand you can just install
most of the packages using simple pip
magics but the problem with that is when
you install a package using pip
it will affect the environment for all
of the notebooks on that machine and
installing a package for one notebook
might break your other notebooks that
have been functioning before
there is another way how to how you can
deal with installing dependencies and
managing them and
that's by creating custom docker images
so with docker you can create fully
reproducible environments and that's
totally fine but it requires a lot of
additional effort some time
wouldn't it be great if you could
dynamically change your environment but
at the same time keep the notebook
the notebook environment isolated and
reproducible and basically that was the
motivation for us jet brace when
building environment manager in data
lore so when you start working on a
notebook in data lore you begin with a
pre-configured based environment and on
top of that you can start installing any
additional libraries that you might need
so using the environment manager
you can search for any package for any
library
choose its version and install it from
the editor ui all the changes that make
that you make to your environment are
kept isolated to a specific notebook
and are saved to an environment file
that could be further like copied to
other notebooks that you might have or
you can use like a notebook as a
template and then clone it to reproduce
the same environment for other notebooks
uh so um yep now let's talk about
getting data from multiple data
providers so in traditional notebooks
it might be hard to understand if a
certain data file of a certain csv file
if it belongs to one notebook or to
several notebooks
you might follow certain conventions
but
to be honest it might become a mess
quite soon so in data lawyer
we solve this problem by attaching the
files to the notebook so
your workspace where you store the
notebooks
it stays clean and you always know which
notebook a file belongs to if you want
to share one file it might be like a
huge dataset between multiple notebooks
you can upload it to workspace files
and
second if
like you ever worked or if you are
working with
any external data sources
there might be a lot of time spent on
context switching between the place
where you retrieve your data for example
an sql ide and a place where you do your
final research
and again yeah that might require a lot
of time a lot of reproducing of
different curies and different places
and eventually um like make might make
you work not reproducible to solve this
in data lore we added uh ability to
connect databases right to your
notebooks so you can connect a lot of
sql databases right from the editor ui
and then reuse these connections across
the other notebooks without having to
write a single line of python code
when you connect a database you will see
the database schema so you'll be able to
navigate it and then you can create sql
cells with native sql
right inside your python notebooks
and when writing sql code you'll get
code completion you'll get syntax
highlighting you by the way you also get
code completion for the table uh columns
names not only for sql functions and
when you uh like your query was executed
after your query is executed
the result would be automatically saved
to upon this data frame so that you
could seamlessly continue
working on it
inside your python code
one more important thing here
like when you connect to a database you
need your credentials and with our
database integration uh the credentials
are stored in a specific authentication
server so by no means they could be
retrieved in the environment by other
people
now let's talk about writing code
without idea support
when you are writing code in a
professional python ide such as for
example pycharm uh you might be familiar
with this tool by jetbrains so you will
get uh like code compilation you will
get documentation on hover quick fixes
refactorings and also all and all of
those fancy features available for
python developers and an ide in
traditional notebooks
you get um
you get less you get just uh a plain
worksheet you might
just add some uh plugins that will be
giving you coding assistance but
probably that could not compare uh to a
professional ide
um and you can all quite often see
people switching like between an id and
a jupiter notebook or between stack
overflow and jupyter notebooks um so to
like to fix this problem in daylor we
made an id a part of
our solution so
i've mentioned a bunch of cool features
such as code completion
contextual documentation quick fixes
refactorings and you get everything
that you are familiar uh with in pycharm
and delore as well for sql we also
reused a lot of code from another
jetbrains ide called datagrip and also
made it available in datalog for working
with sql databases
like not all the
inspections and refactorings are
available in daily lore
that you might be familiar with in
python but we are working on it and for
example you can already rename
a function of methods in our notebooks
that might sound super simple
but to do this correctly you need to do
the full syntax analysis of your code
um
yeah another
pain point of data science and data
analysis teams is probably
sharing
their work quite often people share
their notebooks
as files via messengers or via email and
but like but what if you need to share a
huge data set alongside with your
notebook um some people use git but it
doesn't work really well with uh like uh
uploading big data sets and sharing uh
them through git so um like data
scientists end up storing their data in
one place and their research in another
place um if you share your notebook as a
zebra hive uh like and send it over
to your colleagues or to your teammates
uh
they will spend time on installing the
same environment you had in your drewber
notebook or like in your
yeah in your jupyter notebook and they
will need to fix
potential issues with file paths so
again it requires a lot of time and
effort and in some cases you might need
to share your work with uh like external
people with like some of your
stakeholders for whom your code might be
intimidating and you just don't want to
share like hundreds of lines of
intermediate steps uh to only share like
the final i don't know five or seven
cells
so that's another part of collaboration
and in data lore we like divide
we see several ways of like how people
collaborate uh in their data science and
data analysis workflow the first one is
when you need some help on from your
colleagues on the same piece of code
when you just basically want to work on
the same notebook
the second
collaboration way is
when you work on a project that consists
of multiple notebooks multiple data sets
multiple work artifacts and the third
way as i've mentioned before is like
sharing your work sharing results of
your work externally
for the first two
workflows
we've integrated real-time collaboration
to
notebooks and datalore and it works like
exactly like google docs so you can just
share a link with either viewer edit
access rights to your stakehold to your
colleagues or team members
and they will be able uh to hop on the
same notebook with you and the great
thing about it is that you don't need to
share anything additionally because the
environment and the data is shared
automatically and you are basically
sharing the same computation state so
you will see a collaborator's core
source you can track your collaborator
like throughout the notebook and this
way you can help each other out
on some data science problems um and
yeah like move faster so to say with uh
collaboration
now we also have like shared workspaces
for team projects where like you need to
share where you need to share
the workspace with your colleagues only
once and then like
everyone has access to the notebooks to
the up-to-date state of your projects
without having to commit any changes to
any repositories so you always get
up-to-date states of your work
um and for the la for the last use cases
that i've mentioned for sharing results
of your work uh we also made um
available turning your notebooks into
interactive reports
so what you can do in datalore you can
hide intermediate steps you can just
basically hide the code cells you can
hide even
some outputs and then just hit one
button like publish you can add
interactive controls
to make your reports look interactive
and then just send the link over to your
stakeholders and they will be
opening it just in their browsers no
daily account is required and they'll be
able to manipulate the controls get
their own version get their own copy and
without no without any overwhelming uh
feelings uh about your code they will be
able to get like uh
they
notebooks that you've prepared
recomputed on them
on demand
last but not least
let's talk about
reproducibility
i think this problem is familiar to
everyone who has ever worked with
jupiter notebooks even though we
normally read documents from top to
bottom
in jupiter
it might easily become a mess
on the one hand
it's good because
you might find that you've made a
mistake in the first cell or you need to
add like can you
intermediate stop and you can easily do
it within jupiter but on the other hand
it's a constant source of trouble
because you might execute one cell
multiple times you might just completely
delete a cell you might move the cells
up and down and
it might result
to your work not being
reproducible at all
to mitigate this what you need to do is
to restart the kernel and rerun the
computations from top to bottom just
re-running the computation from top to
bottom won't help because the side
effects will still be there in your code
for example you've declared a variable a
equals two and then you deleted the cell
uh but the state will still know that
there is a variable a equals to but if
another person wants to just reproduce
the results you had
it won't work
so in data lore we've been working for
the last three years to mitigate this
problem and half a year ago we released
the new reactive mode that basically
helps to keep your notebook state in a
consistent order so what it does
it
enforces top-down
recalculation of the cells below the
modified ones it's not just that simple
rerun all from the modified one
underneath it's uh using the framework
called creo it's checkpoint restore and
user space framework which
provides a generic way to implement
backups and restore functionality for
arbitrary running links applications and
is also used by docker among others
so
what is cool about the new approach is
that is language agnostic and works out
of the box for
all of the jupiter kernels available
in data lore and
basically with reactive modes
you can be sure that uh your computation
states is always consistent and that
your work is always reproducible and
this is i think uh is the crucial thing
uh for people in academia and people in
business when their whole career or when
their whole business uh might be just
challenged by a trivial mistake
in a jupyter notebook done by a data
scientist
so
that's it for me today
if you were interested in any of the
features that i've mentioned
during my talk i welcome you to our
jetbrains booth on the second floor and
i'll be conducting demos i will be
conducting live demos of daily lure and
i'll be showing these features that i've
talked about in depth so i'll do these
demos two times today during the coffee
breaks uh one at 2 20 p.m and another
one at 3 50. so please join us and yeah
thanks again for
joining me for this talk and any
questions are welcome
[Applause]
thank you for the talk it was really
amazing now we have uh really 10 15
minutes for questions uh i will first
read the online ones and then i will ask
the room
if they have any questions
so uh why didn't you add this
functionality you presented directly to
the jupiter project
uh so
um like the architecture we have uh in
dailor is a bit different from the one
in jupiter and to fully realize the
potential of data lore
just we started building this tool
internally in jetbrains
thank you uh is data data lore web-based
or standalone func application so we
have a bunch of options how you can use
datalore we have datalog community and
data pro plans which are hosted by
jetbrains and you can just use it in our
cloud by registering via email and we
also offer uh self-hosted versions of
datalore like a private installation of
lore
for companies that you can install on
any kubernetes cluster in like aws azure
gcp accounts or even on on-prem servers
so both options are available thank you
does this follow the standard notebook
format is it possible to export the
notebook and environment to run it
independently of datalog yes uh so we
are jupyter compatible so you can import
jupyter notebooks and export
notebooks in little or
via jupiter format
thank you
how does this compare with the
repo to docker and jupiter hub setup
with the jupiter lab ide
so in data lore
we try to focus on the workflow when
like from fetching the data
to present an uh final result of data
scientist work and
like we want to
empower teams collaboration and we would
say that we make this pass as smooth as
possible without having to um to
configure anything it's just uh super
easy in the product and the product is
tailored for these use cases thank you
is there an advantage advan advantage of
the inbuilt dependency management over
simple virtual environment or is that
what's effectively happening under the
hood
uh so
that's a good question um like
um
when i was a day like when i studied
data science and i created multiple
virtual environments it was always hard
for me to manage them like i didn't have
a visual representation of them and i
always messed up creating creating my
notebooks
in different virtual environments and i
see that it's super transparent when you
can just see the environment uh in the
editor ui and you have full control over
it and uh
yeah just
the
fact that the notebook environment is
isolated prevents the whole service from
crashing for example it might be the
problem for
companies that host their jupiter hub
instances and one person just
installs a package
in the team and
or just updates the dependencies and it
ruins
the whole team's work so i feel that
the fact that the environment is
isolated as a huge pro and being able to
see
what is there running in your notebook
and being able to upgrade with a single
click
is super helpful
thank you two more
uh is a part of data lore included in
python professional
uh no so these products are separate
products because first of all data lore
runs on the web
but yeah i've mentioned that a part of
pycharm is part of datalog so for
example we've integrated coding systems
from pycharm and it's running in the
backend
of datalog
but yeah datalog runs in the map and
pycharm is an ide that is installed
locally on uh computers thank you
does it work with js with the
visualization for instance with cborn
yes sure we like uh deadlord is jupiter
compatible and it supports all the pack
all the packages that are available in
jupiter so we support
like
i would say most of the
utilization packages available also the
interactive one for sure and on top of
that we also have chart cells it's a
specific type of cell where like uh you
can build charts with a few mouse clicks
i can show it's
during my live demo
at the boost
so yeah just we have we support both uh
python packages for the visualization we
also by the way support r i haven't
mentioned that we also have our kotlin
and scholar notebooks
so we support
classic packages and
have some internal visualization tools
as well
thank you
uh while you're answering i already got
two more questions
do people use data lore notebooks to run
data science in production systems do
you recommend doing so
yeah so uh like uh i would say that the
companies that are purchasing the
enterprise version of data lower are
using this in production so that's
their main use case so yeah okay
is the real-time collaboration using the
jupiter lab and ygs ecosystem
uh could you repeat it yes is the real
time collaboration using the jupiter lab
and ygs ecosystem
uh no
at the back end
as far as i understand it has
the same mechanism as google docs so
it's uh like technology is called
something like operational
transformation so it's not using jupyter
lab by any means at the back end for
collaboration
thank you these were the online
questions
does anybody have questions in the room
yes okay
thank you that was an amazing
presentation thank you um
i have a more general question
how
do you see
data law and jet brains engage with the
larger jupiter community in ways that
could benefit the entire jupiter user
and developer community
so first of all
like
we've been developing approaches to
reproduce ability for a long time
just
to be honest when we just started
datalor there was no jupiter kernel and
there was only the so-called date lord
kernel available so we started with
trying to
fight with the problem of jupiter
notebooks or notebooks computational
notebooks and generally like in
reproducibility and we've tried multiple
approach on
reproducible kernels
and we think
that
we have found the approach that could
work for most of the cases
like that's basically the reactive mode
that i've talked a bit uh
during my talk
and uh like for this project when we are
ready to share when we are ready to open
source it i think we'll do this so this
way uh we'll
open source i hope at some points
this reactive uh kernel also to the
jupiter community because i think it's
like the reproduce i love jupiter
notebooks i'm a huge fan of japanese
books and i know that there are a lot of
people who hate japanese notebooks and
they i think they were like talks
at pycon at some point when people said
that they hate the japanese books and i
think that if we fight uh together i
mean like as a community the problem of
reproducibility in jupiter notebooks
it could be treated even more seriously
in the data science world and the whole
community would benefit from it
thank you
any more questions in the room
all right thank you for the ah sorry
okay
thank you
so i saw that you can export notebooks
for
people externally to view them
it's also possible to export interactive
cells with um
pi widgets
yes definitely we support our python
widgets um we don't call it export we
call it publish because exporting is
like a sport exporting file this like
interactive reports they are available
via link uh but here we support ipython
widgets you can use either them for
example or you can use uh the native
interactive controls that we've built in
datalore so that's possible
thanks
any more questions
thank you for the questions and thank
you for the talk yeah thank you very
much